everybody welcome to this week in
startups I'm your host Jason Calacanis
and this is a special 10 part series
we're doing on scaling your startup the
first episode we just completed and that
was fundraising and getting funding for
your startup that's what we hear about
all the time today we're going to talk
about one of the most important topics
that you have to have now the inside of
your company before you start to grow
before you start to scale and that topic
is communications we're going to talk
all about communications internal
external investors team members
co-founders and my guest today are three
of the four fantastic four members or
two of the four fantastic former members
here at this week in startups and launch
our investment company Ashley Whitehurst
is our managing director of syndicates
and San Samantha Sam's August is our
president and she makes sure the whole
system is running so welcome back to the
program
Ashley thanks for having me and Sam
welcome back there's your first
appearance on the scale series that
we're doing this 10-part scale series
and we've been working pretty hard on
these documents to try to really tap
into what we've learned over hundreds of
investments watching a lot of failure
watching a lot of success and Sam
actually ran her own startup as well so
she's got some experience on the other
side of the table if you want to follow
along with this deck it's available at
this week in startups slash Gao so if
you go to this week in startups of scale
you'll see the deck depending on when
you tune in if we've completed all ten
episodes in the series you'll see all
ten decks as one giant deck with about
7080 slides if you're tuning in after
episode 2 or 3 you might just see 20 or
30 slides we're just going to add each
one to each episode to the deck and the
deck will have some links in it and some
ability for you to add notes and if
you're confused about anything so go to
this week in startups comm slash scale
SCE all right Ashley what is our first
topic in our scaling communications at
your startup we're gonna start the very
beginning with co-founder alignment so
in you know in this topic we're gonna
discuss what the priorities are when
first communicating about your startup
so say if you wanna yeah so the top
priority is that you absolutely must
have a line
among the founding team you want to
start discussions early on about your
company mission and values and make sure
you all agree if you don't agree there's
you know it's highly likely that you
won't succeed yeah why are you there I
mean if you have a mission to build air
B&B and you don't like to travel and you
certainly don't want to stay in people's
houses or extra bedrooms or extra
apartments like yeah you probably
shouldn't have joined that startup you
should have joined an enterprise
software company so agreement on the
mission is critical yeah and a lot of
co-founders think oh well you know we
can always flush this out later or
things will change but in most
situations you know at least what I've
seen is that that doesn't happen and it
only gets worse got it and I see here
0.2 agreeing on the roles how does one
go about doing this yeah so with this
one it's it's important that you agree
on a division of responsibilities and
make sure everyone understands there are
certain functions within the company so
having very clearly defined roles you
know within the CEO title CEO title in
the very beginning I think there's gonna
be a lot of overlap but you want to make
sure you have you know who is in charge
of the tech who's gonna be running the
product team who's in charge of sales HR
things like that got it and for people
who have never run a start-up oh boy
they may not even know what the roles
are this is we're having great mentors
investors or board members they can say
listen there's going to be three main
functions at this company or five main
functions of this company you got to
figure out a way to split up this work
and have some intentionality about it
yeah great and then another another
thing that's important is just
understanding each other's communication
style so not only among the co-founding
team but the entire founding team and
initial employees and beyond so you want
to discuss these preferences some people
you know will have expectations early on
about work-life balance things like that
so all of this you just want to discuss
right in the beginning and this could
also include you know introversion
versus extraversion you know how people
how people like to receive feedback
things like that got it
and also I'm assuming here if you're not
communicating well people's minds tend
to wander so sometimes you'll have
somebody who leaves at 5:30 every day
you know
what's going on there and maybe they
have to pick their kids up from school
or you know maybe they're going to yoga
but they're back online for two more
hours and you just didn't see that work
and so your mind can wander and being
candid with each other as co-founders as
to the work style and the communication
style and maybe even feedback some
people don't take feedback very well
they need to like really go slow and
they feel very accused if there's any
criticism or something like that I think
that's always the the problem I see with
founders is they were really not very
good at giving criticism and everybody
wants to focus on what's going well but
the job of the CEO and the founding team
is to be able to be candid and look at
what's not working how should you
deliver the bad news actually
bad news be communicated to each other
so you guys have feelings about that
yeah and we'll talk about we'll talk
about having tough conversations a
little bit later too but but bad news is
always important to share being direct
about it is really really important
talking about what you believe are the
main causes for whatever the bad news is
and and then brainstorming yeah yeah and
also just discuss what to do so
oftentimes you know you'll have a team
member that is a high performer but
having a negative effect on the company
culture or vice versa and so you'll you
know that'll probably add a discussion
that you want to have early on what to
do in those situations and how bad it
needs to get before you know action
needs to be taken ah so you could have
somebody who's well liked but a poor
performer a great performer but causing
chaos in the company and being a jerk
and I guess the founders have to decide
early on how we're gonna handle those
but no founders do right they never talk
about hey what will we do if things go
wrong if we have a fire somebody
especially never go wrong it can't
possibly go wrong but invariably the
people who you hire for those first
couple of years are going to be
different than the people you hire in
the next phase of the company the
scaling phase of the company so really
understanding how you're going to add
people to the team and split up
responsibilities super important that's
right I think roles and responsibilities
are super important if you can build an
org chart of what the company looks like
today with five or six people on it but
what it'll eventually look like when
one person is in doing operations office
management HR marketing and sales and
the other person is doing product design
user testing support I mean sometimes we
have too many roles but to show the org
chart at 30 people when you're only at 6
or 7 is a nice way to sort of understand
how this will change over time yeah and
really understand what each co-founder
wants to be working on and what they're
passionate about that can be you know
helpful too yeah
what's our last one here yeah and of
course it's important to set time and
attention expectations with your loved
one so you definitely want to have
spousal buy-in you want to make sure
that you're communicating what this is
going to take what the time investment
is going to be you know what the risks
are the different types of sacrifices
that your and neva tably going to take
and just make sure that your spouse is
aware of it and you know ultimately ok
with it yeah
spousal or significant other buy-in
something that most people don't spend
enough time on if your three co-founders
and all three of you are married or have
a significant other you really have six
co-founders three of them who aren't in
the office every day but who can have an
impact on the business and making sure
they understand the sacrifice and the
duration of the sacrifice critically
important you know I'm going to put four
years into this business which means I'm
going to be on call essentially and
maybe you have kids or you've got a
spouse who wants to I don't know take
the summer off or take a month and that
lack of alignment with your third
co-founder or fourth co-founder that
that could cost chaos especially for the
person who's trying to make a decision
do I my loyal to the business and I work
all of July and August or am i loyal to
my family or significant other or spouse
who wants to take six weeks every summer
because I don't know they they're
European and that's how they do things
over there and they want to take six
weeks